but she asked a good question
and this question remains
how to organize europe
from a political point of view
and broader than the European Union
it is our historical obligation
than to answer it today
and create indix-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-neuf
I will qualify today before you
a European political community
this new European organization
would allow democratic European nations
adhere to our value base
to find a new space for political cooperation
of security
cooperation in transport energy matters
infrastructure investment
of movement of persons
and in particular of our youth
joining it would not prejudge future membership
to the European Union necessarily
as it would not be closed either
to those who have left the latter